ont passé un peu de temps maintenant
avec le docteur carves de carves bonsoir
bonsoir je suis curieux de vous entendre
sur bas c'est aujourd'hui qu'entre en
vigueur la possibilité pour les
québécois de se réunir à 10 revenant de
trois familles différentes crois que
dans le décret qui était adoptée par
québec
on ne fait pas la distinction des trois
familles mais bon ça c'est une autre
histoire
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous de ces
regroupements à 10,6 prudent je pense
que c'est prudent et on est rendu à
l'étape la pression physique social
psychologique à l'étape actuelle devenez
probablement difficile à apprendre pour
la population la population québécoise a
été discipliné obéissante a suivi les
conseils les recommandations ça fait dix
semaines que les gens sont comme ça
la situation au québec est encore
préoccupant dans la région de montréal
beaucoup moins dans le reste du québec
et probablement que les gens ont besoin
d'une bouffée d'air et bouffée d'oxygène
donc si les choses sont faites dans un
contexte contrôler un environnement
assez contrôlé on peut tranquillement un
peu comme un café l'acquis goode qui
coûta gouttes rampling cafetière
commencé à à passer à des étapes de
déconfinement on peut pas rester il est
finalement pendant des mois et des mois
en confinement total c'est irréaliste
donc c'est normal qu'on passe à autre
chose c'est le fameux principe du
robinet du docteur arruda
nous avons fait une entrevue un peu plus
tôt aujourd'hui avec le pdg d'une
entreprise moderna aux états unis
stéphane bancel et qui nous a annoncé
finalement qu'on était en phase 1 de
développement que c'est aller beaucoup
plus vite qu'il pensait pour trouver un
vaccin
vous êtes etonnez-vous bon on sait qu'on
n'est pas arrivé il faut pas crier
victoire loin de là mais ça vous étonne
qu on connaît aussi rapidement on soit
aussi rapidement arriver à faire des
essais cliniques
alors qu'on soit rapidement arriver à
faire des essais cliniques
non mais qu'on soit assez a aussi
rapidement arriver à dire qu'il ya
peut-être des choses extraordinaires
il faut être très prudent avec ce genre
de choses là vous savez il ya plus d'une
centaine de vaccin en développement sur
la planète
il ya de la compétition entre les états
il ya de la compétition entre les
compagnies de la compétition entre des
petites biotech qui veulent se faire
racheter par des énormes multinationales
donc le marché des vaccins pour la
colite 19 d'un marché planétaire
gigantesque et oui il faut trouver un
vaccin
oui faut aller de l'avant mais vous
savez il faut être très très prudent si
une compagnie avait trouvé un vaccin
disons pour la méningite et que la
compagnie était en phase 1 vous
entendriez jamais parlé inspire mois du
soyez vraiment dans le domaine personne
ne fait des annonces ou quasiment de
phase 1
sauf si ce n'est pour soum ramasser de
l'argent essayer de lever de l'argent
pour continuer à faire de la recherche
dans des domaines très particulier dont
habituellement avant d'aller dire que on
est sur la bonne voie
il va falloir voir qu'est ce que ça
donne et ce que le vaccin est
sécuritaire est ce qu'il y a pas
d'effets secondaires
est-ce que c'est des vrais anticorps
neutralisants ce qu'ils vont perdurer
pendant un minimum de temps on y est un
ensemble de critères
il faut vous allez avoir passé la phase
2 et que si un vaccin se retrouve
vraiment en phase ii à la toute fin et
avec désirs et une efficacité
prometteuse et des qualités pour aller
en phase 3 je pense que là on pourra
commencer a très sérieusement regarder
la compagnie qui produit le vaccin
puisqu'on parle de vaccins dans 96
premières questions du public
ce soit avec la course au vaccin
actuellement est il possible que trois
ou quatre vaccins différents soit
découvert et commercialiser aussi
efficace les indés
l'un comme l'autre alors tout à fait
c'est comme la grippe c'est quand la
lame énergie c'est quand les vaccins
contre le pneumocoque
il ya déjà plusieurs actions sur le
marché par différentes compagnies donc
même je vous dirais il est même fort
programme qu'on se retrouve avec un
scénario de ce genre là où vous ayez 4,5
vaccin produit dans différents pays par
différentes compagnies donc c'est très
probable est explosive si on arrive à
produire un vaccin faut aussi dire il ya
des gros chance pour lui arrive mais il
n'ya rien d'absolu vous savez le vih ça
fait depuis maintenant plus de 35 ans
qu'on cherche un vaccin et on est
toujours en train de le chercher alors
c'est pas parce qu'on veut produire un
vaccin qu'on va y arriver à 100%
est ce qu'un deuxième question est ce
qui est ce que les produits
désinfectants pour les maîtres que l'on
s'implique plusieurs fois par jour
peuvent augmenter la guinée de la
rhinite c'est une inflammation là je
pense du conduit ne sont là guinée de
saisonnière et les symptômes qui en
découlent bah écoutez ce serait peu
probable à moins que vous soyez
allergique à la quelque chose qui est
contenu dans le gène des fois c'est pas
forcément de jeunes alcoolisés mais il
ya des substrats des produits de qui
vont donner des odeurs particulières ou
des additifs qui vont être ajoutés et à
ce moment là mais c'est pas tellement
larini le parc ans il faut dire c'est
qu'on est dans la saison d'allergies et
qu'il ya des gens qui font des rhinites
non pas probablement parce qu'ils
utilisent leurs gènes mais tout
simplement parce qu'ils font des
allergies a quelque chose dans
l'environnement qui commence à cette
période de l'année
nos questions de carole boulet dr weiss
devrait éviter de faire des soins du
visage
électrolyse au visage de mes clientes
cas pour ce faire elles devront enlever
leurs masques protecteurs
une question qui est difficile à cette
étape ci parce que c'est pas un service
ultra essentiel on va dire et donc à ce
moment là où il ya un possible risque
n'oubliez pas c'est le visage le visage
c'est près de près de la bouche près du
nez si vous avez du virus est là par là
que vous allez l'ex crette souvent les
gens vont être relativement proches les
uns des autres donc oui vous pourriez
porter hamas et une visière
ça va être difficile de faire porter un
masque à votre patient parce que s'ils
voulaient travailler sur son visage avec
un masque
c'est pas évident donc ça va il y aura
certaines part hier à faire ce genre de
choses là ça va revenir à un moment
donné mais il va falloir y aller étape
par étape mais dr weiss merci beaucoup
c'est tout le temps qu on avait je vous
souhaite une excellente fin de semaine
et au plaisir de se reparler très
bientôt vous aussi bonne semaine avant
ici